apoptosis is the program cell death  where cell dies and blips out the  blabbing cell is cleared up by the  macrophages which ensures there are not  much debris that can create inflammatory  responses apoptosis could be  pathological or physiological now  apoptosis can occur via several Pathways  one popular pathway is intrinsic pathway  which is mediated by cleft caspase 3.  there are sensors of bcl2 family that  that allows the activation of backs or  bad which pokes hole in the mitochondria  releases cytochrome c cytochrome c can  further activate a puff one which lead  to caspase cleavage and thereby  apoptosis of the cell there would be DNA  fragmentation and bleving out of  portions of the cell which is further  taken up by other phagocytotic cell if  you want to know more watch the full  video